what is happening there citizens of
the reject Nation Greg here today
joined by my co-host John how are you I
am enjoying listening to the the really
rich baritone of your voice right now how
are you good I sound like Michael win God
get that perfect shot man oh yeah I gotta get
sick more I'm in recovery mode guys but we got
some exciting news exciting reports here rumors
I'm seeing it all over social media right now I
saw it on comicbook.com as well I was like Wow
them I wonder if this is actually true we got
information about Captain America 4 New World
Order and of course Thunderbolts and how this
is all setting up more mutants and specifically a
man with claws oh no that's the joke I was gonna
well I'd be into the hilarious joke the audience
is laughing laboriously due to my joke mine oh oh
dead Deadpool from X-Men Origins stop it Michael
wincott commands anyway leave a like people here
we go here we go here we go so here's the basic
report of what's going on do you remember an
eternals how um after Cersei saved the day there
was Tiamat the the celestial poking up to the
sky apparently that's gonna be in Ireland now all
right cool and that people are inhabiting it how
I don't know how loud how do they convert that
to an island they hollowed it out just use the
entire body cavity because like you just have like
a dome and a palm I actually do have a theory as
though what kind of people might be inhabiting it
and by saying it like that you probably already
guess what my theory is going with that President
Ross he will be General Thunderbolt Ross will
not be president Ross good for him yeah good for
him he's been working his way up the ladder he's
been trying really hard for a while they want
something from that Island which is they they
have the rare metal adamantium with that you know
comes all kinds of territorialism people feeling
like they're being invaded and taken advantage
of you know it's kind of like how the Americas
were found what are you talking about well you
know how there were like people just living
here enjoying their life we were all living on a
big hand ah they needed us to come and show them
how to make the big hand work for that came in
and said we want the gold you got here and the
gold now being adamantium see it's commentary
political commentary New World Order you get
it oh my God Marvel's woke but this will also tie
into Thunderbolts the last two films out of phase
five are gonna be Captain America and World Order
and Thunderbolts the other rumor is going around
is that the island is actually going to be called
ganosha which as many of you guys know is a famous
island from uh the X-Men Comics it's actually
I think it's in dark Phoenix at one point right
it is magnetic yeah yeah I think it is but yeah
Magneto is like very much associated with the
porn who's like running ganosha not saying he's
going to be in this but it could be a setup for
what's to come for that so yeah the Thunderbolts
will reportedly be taking place at least somewhat
over there this team of dreaming Celestial
Island place that people inhabit as well this is
obviously going to be setting up a lot for what's
to come for phase five most obviously if this is
true it's a direct tie-in to X-Men it feels like
every other film we're getting closer and closer
to directly tying it in I know we got Deadpool
three coming but they've already established it
that's going to be taking place before Logan so
perhaps that's still taking place within the fox
Universe timeline itself not exactly our main MCU
timeline regardless I think this is a really cool
setup and with it being an island that's going
to be inhabited I'm wondering if the theory is
actually going to finally be coming true of that
whole thing with the dream and Celestial omitting
some kind of energy that creates the mutagine
or activates immunogene that looks what if in
fact the people living there are indeed already
mutants you know Sean what do you think about
this thought process I'm having that would be
crazy I think it would still be little abrupt
given no no John I don't care about it I think Sam
Wilson is Captain America I care about mutants yes
right and we have a whole founded X-Men Colony
right here they've all got powers and costumes
and planes and stuff it's gonna be awesome I
like this as a concept and I'm excited to be
surprised by what it actually turns out to be
I mean it's gonna be 2024 this movie's coming
out unless they move it so you know they can't use
the X-Men yet or cast new ones yet so yeah I don't
know 25 yeah yes and that will be when phase
six starts yeah so it makes what we see here
you know won't be able to visually give us the
entire realized X-Men so you know I'm tempering
expectations but I think it's smart to use Tiamat
and I think it's interesting I mean adamantium is
a terrestrial metal as of the comics but I think
it could be interesting if they're implying that
maybe some sort of celestial intervention further
legitimizing the eternals might have created both
a reaction that could have sparked the X Gene to
awaken in but also could have you know created
some kind of adamantium here like I think at
least for what it's doing for Captain America
and the Thunderbolts it's a really cool idea uh
for what it means for the overall X-Men I'm not
like oh my God if Wolverine's about to show up I
hope he does I think he should I think he should
people like that I think someone should have
a baby and then what will you call him Logan
looks up Shameless X 24. I mean some people
were also thinking that it might be cooler if
they instead of making a ganosha that they made
it the character forgive me if I'm pronouncing
this wrong I've only read the name krakowa which
is essentially is a mutant but an island island
mutant if you've seen avatar The Last Airbender
you know those kind of characters are awesome
words it's an island no it's a turtle you know
that's kind of the same basic concept right there
yeah which would be a neat way to go about it I
like what it's setting up for adamantium because
if you look at Black Panther wakanda forever which
set the stage for the governments around the world
all wanting vibranium as like the ultimate power
source adamantium arguably could be stronger at
least maybe that's what the government's even
thinking themselves so this would actually fall
in line with everything that we have been setting
up maybe not as overtly or as obvious but that
would be uh the right direction I think to go
after phase four then if you're ending phase
five we got something better than adamantium we
need to get the leader back in here so we can
go extract that oh yeah World War Hulk [__]
yeah and then get this man an adamantium Shield
yeah yeah [__] like that yeah I won then you
would have a Thunderbolts movie that would be
very sort of suicide squad-esque and come with
a good sort of moral quandary at the center of
it that then maybe Captain America is able to
sway some of them away from versus you know
others who will further uh hold tight hold faster
you mean like the Thunderbolts are trying to get
this adamantium [__] and they realize like oh no
but if we give this over to president Red Hulk yes
really bad this could be really bad and also
people just live here now apparently and have
a whole society and we shouldn't maybe just like
trample through their Village as much like in The
Suicide Squad it just kill people wantingly why
I'm excited for this is not because of the actual
movie itself but because of what they're setting
up for other movies down the road Marvel you
continue to do what you do best yeah I can keep
me questioning what's Captain America gonna do
while the nations of the world argue over adamant
that is an interesting precedent to suffer him
if he is there to defend the people of Timo to
whatever the I live I don't know if the arms can
call Kenosha or not but if he is there to defend
those people it is a nice reversal on the whole
thing especially with him being called Captain
America yeah the kind of commentary sticking up
for the people who are about to be colonized
and hey I mean ganosa is in the Indian Ocean
team what is in the Indian Ocean there's enough
here to suggest that that's probably what it will
be down the line I think this will be the early
stages they'll find that people are living there
and that's that'll be it and then event actually
it'll be like a Haven that's all like cool and
blade runnery but not yeah it'll be a cyberpunk
hand that are living on yeah it will have to be
I'm like the have what's the surface area on this
thing how how much of a city could we don't know
how you form a city I don't understand Hollow it
out it makes no sense I mean Tiamat wakes up at
certain points in the comics like this question
we're gonna do about that see how they live here
yeah it makes me go wait a minute how is
any of this gonna work please acknowledge
but also here any tricky decision just
make it X-Men and you're good all right
guys well what do you think about these
plot reveals if they are true do they
excite you do you care do you think it's
all [__] if your thoughts down below
it's all true guys subscribe I got this
we're so close like subscribe and send us
dude you got the most Italian name at the patreon
page I think it's both of us yeah both of us I
think appreciate that we're both part Italian
Greg's more Italian than me it's often something
we argue about and he holds in my face as a sign
of dominance but you you're more Italian than the
both of us that's what I love about you Gabe
I hope you're at least a little bit Italian so
this shout out works but more than that I hope
that you are having a lovely holiday season I
assume that you're a Catholic and that you're
you know feeling guilty while also trying to be
as generous as possible to your loved ones you're
as generous as possible to us you could be Asian
and uh oh goodness he could be you could be Asian
in which case dominantly an Asian name John oh wow
well this is awkward hey Italian Asian I just hope
you're doing well that's that's all I care about
I I love you and I'm pleased to have you
still stick around 2020 yeah kick ass